ça évolue d'heures en or par rapport aux
informations que nous avons les combats
de rue sont en effet toujours très
intenses tout comme les bombardements
qui sont sans qui sont effectués sans
relâche sur la ville de severedonext par
les forces russes on a appris ce matin
que le palais des glaces qui est un des
symboles de la ville a été bombardée
puis a été quasiment entièrement détruit
puisque c'est bombardements ont provoqué
un incendie toutes ces
toutes ces précisions étaient de données
par le gouverneur de Louhans que je vous
rappelle que pour les forces russes il
est essentiel de conquérir cette ville
de cvhodones puisqu'elle permettrait aux
Russes d'avoir accès à la route et à
cramator ce que vers la route qui mène
vers cramator ce qui serait un point
essentiel un pour conquérir
l'intégralité de la région fontra à
l'air de Louhans en ce qui concerne la
ville voisine de Lucie de chance cette
ville se trouve en face de sévérodona
c'est bien elle est pour l'instant
toujours entièrement contrôlé par les
Ukrainiens mais elle aussi très
sévèrement bombardée de façon continue
par les forces russes et on a appris et
bien que une évacuation de civil avait
pu avoir lieu il y avait parmi eux trois
enfants dernière information
mirailow podilia qui est un des
conseillers du président et bien il a
indiqué on parlait hier le président les
elinski avait parlé de sans soldats qui
décédait chaque jour et dans l'est du
pays et bien finalement ce chiffre a été
revu à la hausse il se situe est plutôt
entre 100 à 200 soldats qui mouraient
tous les jours dans cette guerre